this may be a little different than the
last giant cycle of technological
innovation when I think things were a
lot less formal in America one huge
cycle has been education high quality
institutions of higher education now
it's not always true we've got to
remember Bill Gates and Steve Jobs who
were probably the two most famous
high-tech figures of the last 30 years
are both college dropouts Michael Dell
who is not really a technology figure
but runs a big technology company is a
college dropout and even Sergey Brin and
Larry Page found at Google while they
are certainly not college dropouts did
drop out of their phd programs and never
finish their PhDs having said that it's
obvious that the last several waves of
innovation in digital technology that
kind of thing that I write about have
been generated by higher education
institutions of high quality the pre PC
era the reason that a lot of those
companies were clustered around Boston
was MIT we still have companies being
spun out of them IT today you may have
heard of irobot you know which makes the
Roomba vacuum and a bunch of actually
military robots there there an MIT
spin-off there is a company's spun off
by MIT that are working on you know
basically electronic paper and a number
of other things but the PC revolution
Stanford played a much bigger role in
that so a lot of you know Yahoo Google
quite a few other of those Silicon
Valley companies the reason Silicon
Valley is Silicon Valley is Stanford
obviously not everyone went to Stanford
but it has been a huge catalyst an area
that at one time I think as recently as
30 or 35 years ago was primarily a fruit
and flower growing area and now is
called Silicon Valley